ja muss sagen ich habe mich heute
wahnsinnig aufgeregt die sah
gesundheitsminister kommt die ecke
gebogen mit treuherzigem augenaufschlag
und verkündet sensationelles was im kern
auch skandalös ist denn er sagt in
wahrheit haben wir hier in deutschland
schon 1 quote von 80 prozent also 80
prozent der erwachsenen sind zweimal
geimpft und 84 prozent sind einmal gehen
das sind ungefähr fünf prozent mehr als
man bisher gedacht hat das sind übrigens
auch 3,5 millionen leute ungefähr das
ist eine metro metropole von der größe
berlins da wir uns über die frage
unterhalten haben was funktioniert in
deutschland alles nicht am ende der
merkel er diese skandalöse gesundheits
und architektur deutschlands bringt es
fertig dass wir uns sozusagen über ein
halbes oder ein jahr lang hinweg auf das
marode bett dieser behörde gekettet sind
und allen einschränkungen unterworfen
sondern verfahren war am ende es war
eine unnötig so schlimm war es nicht wir
haben jetzt seit einem vierteljahr
erleben wir das trommelfeuer auf die
ungeimpften die müssen unbedingt weil
sie machen den rest krank und dann
wird's wieder die intensivstation alle
belegt wir kennen denen die sagen und
den war das gar nicht mehr nötig 80
prozent impfquote ist das was man als
herdenimmunität bezeichnet jetzt würde
in der katholischen glocke das kirche
das glöckchen geläutet werden immun ist
deutschland in wahrheit schon da geht's
los
der lothar wieler der chef des rk ii hat
im vergangenen dezember gesagt zwei
drittel und es werden 66 prozent sind
schon immun dann wurde später wegen des
neuen virus typs nachgebessert das
müssten schon 80 prozent jetzt haben wir
die auch was tut die ich nenne sie
einfach mal weil die mir sowas von gegen
den strich gehen was du die korona mafia
sie sagt das reicht immer noch nicht
natürlich vorneweg herr lauterbach das
reicht nicht sie würden ja alle
arbeitslos da durch sie hätten ja kein
thema mehr das kann nicht so bleiben
ersparen selber versucht natürlich
dieses versagen der behörde
runterzuspielen und sagt wir brauchen
keine weiteren
beschränkungen mehr im herbst und winter
ja das ist ja wirklich das ist ja die
unverschämtheit schlechthin wir hätten
jetzt anspruch darauf auf den berühmten
freedom day in dänemark gab es dem mit
75 prozent ins rote wir haben inzwischen
80 und wann kommt er bei uns der kommt
natürlich jetzt mit herrn spahn und herr
lauterbach da nicht da kann ich nur
hoffen dass die koalition die jetzt
ausgehandelt nehmen sie es bitte mit in
ihre partei das ist eine partei der
freiheit das in dieser
koalitionsvereinbarung drinsteht dass
bei so ner impfquote alle beschränkungen
fallen gelassen werden also viele in
deutschland braucht den frieden das ich
kann sie beruhigen ermitteln danach mit
dem da ich habe große sympathien für
allein schon weil es einfach mal
symbolisch auch zeit was der
normalzustand in diesem land ist der
normalzustand ist dass wir unsere
grundrechte waren im chor und david
reisens der riesige skandal ist ja
eigentlich dass wir mal wirklich höchst
sensible grundrechtseingriffe bei über
monate hatten und ist dafür immer eine
ganz besondere begründung braucht die
wirklich für freiheits einschränkungen
notwendig ist und jetzt zeigt sich im
nachhinein na ja unsere datenlage die
stimmte jetzt gar nicht vielleicht war
die begründung gar nicht mehr da das
zeige ich ein riesiger skandal besonders
weil die politische dass der politische
diskurs hat ja war ja auch ausser rand
und waren derweil auch von den fuß auf
den kopf gestellt es mussten sich
diejenigen rechtfertigen die grundrechte
und freiheitsrechte in diesem land
verteilt haben die wollen wirklich mit
hohn und spott in den sozialen medien
rechtslage und shops koran und die
jährigen und diejenigen die immer wieder
die krassesten maßnahmen gefordert haben
die wurden beklatscht in unserem land
und eigentlich muss es genau anders
herum sagen und deswegen glaube ich
brauchen wir wieder mehr und
freiheitsgefühl auch und deswegen habe
ich sympathien auch für den frieden also
ich kann sie beruhigen die fdp war ja
auch in der korona pandemie unter der
wir haben die haben schon den abgrenzung
zu afd die der vortrag und nicht
betrachten
fdp in allen reden von herrn lindner im
bundestag hat ja diesen kurs verfolgt
freiheitseinschränkung zurücknehmen es
gab ja auch abstimmungen über diesen
über diesen notstand dem wir
ausgeliefert sind das sind ja auch die
parlamente außer kraft gesetzt worden
aber ich will meinen wahlkampf hat fdp
überhaupt nicht thematisiert wo dieses
dieses offensive wir wollen wieder alle
freiheit stand auf den plakaten war auf
freiheit braucht verbündete wenn man
sich die umfragen anguckt wie so leute
uns gewählt haben sagen 70 prozent war
sie weiter ausgeführt junge war ich
gerade die rinder den kommen wir gleich
noch mal zu gerade die haben uns wegen
das freiheitsgefühl gewirkt weil die
auch diejenigen waren die am stärksten
die korona maßnahmen abgelehnt haben 75
prozent haben bereits gesagt sie finde
ich vergessen sie litten unter sozialer
isolation aber ich möchte jetzt auch gar
nicht die debatte auf die stimmen die
für eine aufwertung der masken pflicht
in teilen ja kein
wurde damit wahlkampf gemacht nein damit
wird kein wahlkampf gemacht warum nicht
wenn irgendwo in der einstellung seiner
wahl
ausschließen wir haben aber man muss
schon sagen das beängstigende an der
dieser tatsache ist ja dass es durchaus
erfolgreich war auf die ängste in der
bevölkerung zu setzen wir erinnern uns
wie hart markus söder damals durch
gerissen hat und wie gut dass den
umfragewerten getan hat auch bei der die
union insgesamt war ja zum teil über 36
prozent als man darauf setzte die ängste
der menschen zu finden muss man zwischen
fragen was heißt denn setzte die engsten
dort befeuert worden die sind doch erst
geschaffen worden ja ich bin immer etwas
zurückhaltend bei der these dass man
irgendetwas in der bevölkerung an blasen
kann was nicht da auch dort na ja das
ist meine erfahrung ist schon blasen
weil ja politiker deshalb singulär ist
weil sie eben nicht ein reines
technokraten thema ist mache ich eine
energiereform oder nicht sondern es
trifft wirklich archetyp ische grund
psychologische anlagen also wer sich
wirklich bedroht fühlt und stolz sagen
ich gehe nicht mehr aus mir alles
liefern den erreichst du mit solchen wir
machen was immer es kostet wir handeln
den erreichst du damit und das ist dass
bedenkliche daran einerseits dass es in
der bevölkerung einen veritablen strang
von menschen gibt die tatsächlich er für
die aufgabe von freiheitsrechten sind
wenn sie dafür sicherheit bekommen und
andererseits das ist eine politik gibt
die man zumindest nicht von dem verdacht
frei sprechen kann damit ganz konkret
und aktiv und sehr abgezockt
politik zu machen dass das ist schon ein
reiz spielt auch da noch mal über zu in
nordrhein-westfalen hat sich dagegen die
flächen der kleine ausgangssperre
gewährt was für e mails haben unsere
minister zum teil bekommen von der fdp
wie wir menschenleben gefährden man
konnte das überall nachlesen gestern hat
das kinderrad in bayern entschieden die
ausgangssperre in markus so dass ich
noch auf gespielt hat als der der hüter
der
menschen wurde gestern wieder vor
gericht auch gesagt okay das war nicht
rechtlich so
notwendig und da möchte ich dann die fdp
verteidigt ich glaube schon dass mir die
konstruktiv kritische partei im
parlament waren die den corona virus
nicht geleugnet haben für
freiheitsrechte einstand da kann jeder
immer sagen auch im nachgang ein
bisschen härter an der stelle oder an
der stelle aber dass auch politisch
durchzustehen habe ich meinen größten
respekt vor christian endler und auch
für wolfgang kubicki da die echten
rückhalt glaube ich gedacht haben und
dafür wurden wir auch belohnt
die fdp als am besten gemacht mich hätte
mir gern noch mehr gewünscht als
nächstes würde ich nicht auch hier auch
noch mehr hier
dank aussprechen wir brauchten ja
irgendwann an dem man noch festhalten
konnte kommt hier war der mine licht ein
licht im himmel aber was ich sagen muss
zu dem thema mit dass die dass die
menschen ist noch selbst haben und die
angst nicht nur von der politik gemacht
wurde da stimme ich komplett zu ich
wollte heute abend eigentlich noch auf
einen auf nun auf den abend event gehen
und dann haben die mir die einleitung
wieder geschickt zweijährige habe mich
zurückziehen ich gehe nirgendwo hin wo
die zweijährige erst entstand dann
einfach mehr zu schreiben das ist in
ordnung wir finden die 2g regel auch
nicht gut wir müssen es leider machen
kommen zurück ach mensch nena wir
verstehen ja dass du immer deine extrem
ansicht mehr bildteilen muss aber da
kenne ich doch keine sau merkt doch
keiner wenn du es jetzt mal bricht
kommen doch einfach zu uns du bist doch
geimpft und in dem moment als ich diese
nachricht gelesen habe ich
zurückgeschrieben a sind meiner ansicht
nicht extrem sondern was ich finde
normal b dass ihr es überhaupt normal
findet menschen auszugrenzen unter noch
mir vorzuwerfen wie sollte jetzt nicht
meine extremen ansichten unter die leute
bringen dass die zweijährige jetzt
irgendwas komisches wäre und das glaube
ich ich glaube krone hat das schlimmste
in menschen angebracht und das war
denunziantentum und bewarb sich bei
dieser nachricht merkel dieses nein das
sind die regeln ist es doch in ordnung
wenn sie sich nicht impfen lassen wollen
sollen sie draußen bleiben und dafür
nicht auch da bin ich auch da das hat
nicht nur die politik geschafft das
haben auch die menschen geschaffen ich
will aber nochmal drei
schlussfolgerungen für die politik
ziehen kurz vielleicht zum abschluss wir
haben wir noch eine interessante
exkursion drei schlussfolgerungen
stellen sich für mich erstens lauterbach
darf unter keinen umständen gesundheit
zwei bieler würde ich als neue regierung
entlassen und einen menschen einstellen
der für die digitalisierung des
gesundheitssystems sorgt und zwar mit
hochdruck und drittens jens sparen darf
nicht cdu-vorsitzender werden so das
sind meine drei schluss
der eigentliche skandal ist ja wie kommt
man plötzlich zu so absurden
abweichungen zahlen na ja das kann man
bald erklären weil wir gar nicht
erfassen wenn wir impfen wir wissen
nicht wen wir geimpft haben sondern wir
zählen die leeren ampullen und versuchen
daraus ich rechne jetzt wäre es ist das
ist eigentlich absurd und da kommt dann
wieder der die daten angst der deutschen
mit durch und man muss ja sich auch klar
machen zu den 80 prozent geimpften
kommen immer noch die genesenen hinzu
die alle stimmen gewesen sei als in
deutschland bei 7 ja ja also eigentlich
wäre ford alles auf machen wir könnten
die wii heraus gehen aber ist der alte
frau sehen wer den wir früher woche für
woche erlebt haben nach dem wochenende
sind ja die gemeldeten corona zahlen
immer wieder abgestürzt weil daheim den
behörden nicht gearbeitet haben ja die
party gemeldet worden sind am montag kam
waren völlig unzuverlässig und dann ging
es am dienstag mittwoch wieder hoch und
dann haben die zahlen mutmaßlich
ungefähr gestimmt am donnerstag freitag
und dann ging es wieder runter und daran
ist ja über mindestens ein jahr nichts
geändert worden man hat das immer wieder
gesehen jede woche dass die zahlen nicht
stimmen hat einfach laufen lassen die
gesundheitsämter sind halt nicht in
ordnung sowie in berlin einfach nicht
richtig die welt würde das ist halt so
das hängt jetzt von den
koalitionsverhandlungen unseren jungen
wahrscheinlich im bundestag da kannst du
ja dann wenigstens schon mal dafür
sprechen und noch eine kleine private
anekdoten
ich habe mich ja nicht in deutschland
verlassen sondern in österreich da ging
es eine spur schneller und dann ziehe
ich ja eigentlich gar nicht zur
deutschen statistik oder obwohl ich hier
wohne ich habe dann stehen digitale den
digital impfpass habe ich dann hier
beantragte apotheke dann schauen wir
genau anders die da gemacht haben und
dann steht plötzlich drinnen im ford
deutschland wie ist denn die impfquoten
ist ich weiß man dass ähnlich wie wie es
wie es hier glaube laura ja die frage
ist jetzt auch zu niedrig oder sollte er
schon bei 80 prozent
meine ist so um die 70 prozent das ist
ja für mich jeder größe ist kann ich war
in österreich kürzlich weil ich dort
eine lesung hatte und dann komme ich ins
hotel keine maske ich kommen sie werden
keine maske ich komme die shopping-mall
keine maske ich habe erst mal geschockt
den ganzen tag aber was ich dazu sagen
wenn es nicht einfach wenn auch wieder
in gewisser form eingeschränkt aber das
größte die größte schande finde ich ja
das wäre überhaupt mal masken frei
hatten in deutschland einfach
durchgezogen wird ich find messer man
macht wenigstens mal jetzt ist die maske
weg und wenn sie dann wieder sein was
machen sie wieder aber es wird einfach
durchgezogen das für mich das größte
versagen daran sollte man sollte man
messen ob in berlin jetzt auch 150
prozent der bevölkerung geimpft sind
das neueste ist ja wenn man darüber
nicht denn wir werden das ja noch mal
diskutieren
diesen wahl skandal in berlin das
neueste was ich da jetzt gelesen habe in
einer aussendung des tagesspiegel da
sich in der frau gemeldet die hat im
wahllokal einen schon ausgefüllten
wahlzettel bekommen da war schon spd
angekreuzt die hatten ein geworfen weil
sie sowieso wählen wollte und erst
hinterher aufgefallen das war ja wohl
nicht in nord und in berlin kommt immer
noch was dazu und wir machen das neue
berlin sangen dann kommen die arme gänze
nicht mehr an wissen haben wir machen
[Musik]